[Applaus]
[Musik]
Vladimir Putin ist besessen von
Geschichtsbüchern ganz besonders und das
ist wohl bekannt von solchen die sich
mit der glorreichen imperialen
Vergangenheit von Mütterchen Russland
beschäftigen und er beläst es nicht nur
beim Lesen in seinen eigenen berühmt
berüchtigten historischen Exkursen
preist Putin mit besonderem Alpha 2
historische Monarchen Peter den großen
und Katharina die Große und warum meine
Lieben Zuschauer nun nicht nur weil
Peter der erste und Katharina die zweite
die einzigen Hersteller des russischen
Imperiums waren die den Ehrentitel der
oder die große bekam und Putin für sich
selbst ähnlichen historischen Glanz
erstrebt nein es waren auch just diese
beiden Monarchen die einen großen Teil
der heutigen Ukraine für Russland
vereint haben Putin geht sogar noch
einen großen Schritt weiter für ihn ist
ist unstrittig dass die Ukraine ein
historischer Teil Russland sei und damit
auch ihre Geschichte und ihr Volk so ist
Putin 2016 vor dem Toren des gremmels
eine Statue von wlady mit dem großen
errichten dem 10 jahrhundert Großfürst
des Fürstentum war und diese Tiere los
war nach der Standardversion der
russischen Geschichtsschreibung die
Keimzelle des russischen Staates für
Putin ist der alte slawische Großfürst
Wladimir natürlich ein vollblutrose auch
wenn er von seiner Herkunft her wohl
eher warreger also ein Wikinger war aber
unbestritten war Wladimir Jena Herrscher
der 988 für sich und die ganze Rose das
Christentum und damit sozusagen
Mütterchen Russland Geist und
herzbluteinflusste die heutige Ukraine
war dabei in Putins Geschichtsbild nur
der Schauplatz jemand der die Putin
denkt sie keinen Sinn darin von einer
Geschichte der Ukraine zu sprechen
angeblich hat tut dir schon 2008 den
ehemaligen US-Präsidenten George Bush
ins Gesicht gesagt die Ukraine sei keine
richtiges Land und noch Vorabend der
total Invasion mit der der schreckliche
Krieg begann den wir heute in Ukraine
miterleben müssen Beschuldigte der Kreml
Herrscher sein Vorgänger das russische
Reich verraten und zerstört zu haben
indem er eine Neue Republik gründete die
ukraineische sozialistische und Wert
Republik 1922 also vor genau 100 Jahren
wurde diese dann zu einem Bestandteil
der neu gegründeten Sowjetunion und nach
deren Zerfall 1991 vor über 30 Jahren
wieder ein unabhängiger Staat alles was
wir heute von Putin sehen und hören
deutet darauf hin dass er sich selbst
als ein neuer großer in der russischen
Geschichte sieht als ein Anführer mit
der Mission die Wiederherstellung des
bröckelnden russischen Reiches zu
bewerkstelligen
dann sind diesem Sinne sagte Putin am 9
juni 2022 ein Treffen mit junge
Unternehmern zwei Dinge erstens dass die
Ukraine kein souveränes Land sein und
niemals sein werde er sprach sogar von
einer Kolonie und zweitens verglich er
sich mit Peter dem Großen der 21 Jahre
lang im Großen Nordischen Krieg gegen
Schweden kämpfte um Russland zu wahre
Größe zu verhelfen aber damit erstmal
genug wir sind hier bei visualpolitik
nicht im Geschichtsunterricht ich meine
keine Frage die Geschichte spielt eine
sehr wichtige Rolle bei dem was heute
geschieht aber andererseits kann die
Vergangenheit niemals die Gegenwart
verändern oder die Zukunft vor bestimmt
denn völlig unabhängig davon ob die
Ukraine nun ein Teil Russland war oder
nicht oder ob ihre Einwohner nun
russisch sprechen oder nicht heute ist
sie ein unabhängiges und zu werdes Land
das ist genauso unbestritten wie heute
die USA Australien Kanada und Irland vom
Vereinigten Königreich unabhängig sind
ihre Vergangenheit als Teil des
britischen Empire und die Tatsache dass
man auf Englisch spricht geben London ja
auch kein historisches Recht auf eine
Invasion und eine erneute Einverleibung
aber den russ die Staatschef ist das
vollkommen egal 2021 veröffentlichte er
ein ellenlange Abhandlung über die
historische Einheit von Russen und
Ukrainern ein Dokument in dem Putin
argumentiert das Russen und Ukrainer ein
und dasselbe Volk bilden das Moskau nun
auf Biegen und Brechen wieder
zusammenführen müsste auf Biegen und
Brechen das heißt eben auch mit
brutalster Gewalt
[Musik]
exakt das hat Putin am 24 Februar
versucht als er seine Ehre witzige
Ukraine Invasion startete von der er
dachte dass Sie ruckzuck zum Erfolg
führt und höchst ruhmreich für ihn
ausgehen würde für alle wissen kam es
ganz anders zehn Monate später hat Putin
keine Chance mehr ein neues Imperium zu
errichten seine russisches Reich
relauncht ist eine mega flott ganz im
Gegenteil sieht es eher so aus als
dürfte historisch für den Untergang des
kolonialen Russlands verantwortlich
zeichnen
sein ukrainefeldzug hat die russische
Armee zerrüttet und demoralisiert eine
Truppe die er noch vor kurzem als
zweitstärkste Armee der weltpries und
die nun von Niederlage zu Niederlage
schlingert 190.000 Soldaten bildeten die
erste invasionstruppe inzwischen wurden
auf russische Seite schätzungsweise
100.000 Mann getötet oder verwundet
symptomatisch weil ich Versenkung der
Moskva ist Flagships der Spaß mehr
Flotte durch einen Gegner der selbst
keine Marine mehr hat im Dezember
geschah etwas weiteres bis dato
Undenkbares ukrainische Drohne mehrere
hundert Kilometer hinter der Front auf
zwei offenbar ungeschützten
Militärflugplätzen beschädigten dort
stationierte strategische fernbombe das
heraus russische Militär hat sich
schlechter geschlagen als ich es mir je
hätte vorstellen können es ist zu früh
um eine Siegesparade zu planen aber ich
glaube die Ukraine stehen kurz davor
eine unumkehrbare Dynamik zu erreichen
solange wir der Westen Ihnen weiterhin
zur Seite stehen benches ehemaliger
kommentierender General der US
Streitkräfte in Europa ehrlich gesagt
eine Herrschaft der sich so arg
verkalkuliert und galoppiert wird doch
zum schlimmsten Feind aller russischen
Großmarkt Ambitionen
[Musik]
ein gutes Beispiel für den gescheiterten
Feldzug ist die strategisch wichtige
Stadt kopians im gebietverkehr ein
halbes Jahr lebte diese Stadt unter
russischer Besatzung als Kreuzungspunkt
von Bahnlinien und Straßen wurde sie zu
einer der wichtigsten Basen der
russischen Kriegsmaschinerie hier wurde
der Nachschub für die Front im Norden
sortiert und abgefertigt und dennoch hat
die Armee der Ukraine Mitte September
diese Stadt fast im Handstreich zurück
wollten ihre blau gelbe Flagge wieder
gehst
[Musik]
ein anderes dramatisches Beispiel war
der Fall von Person die Stadt im Süden
der Ukraine hing schon voller Plakate
wonach sie für immer russisch sei der
Kreml war sogar so weit gegangen die
Stadt und des Verwaltungsgebiet wäre
sonst so annektieren und trotz der
formellen alexion all der hurra
patriotischen transparente und
vollmundigen Erklärungen mussten sich
die Russen 8 Monate nach ihrem Einmarsch
wieder über den Nether zurückziehen die
einzige von ihnen eroberte regionale
Hauptstadt ist seither wieder zwei los
Ukraine
doch das Schlimmste dürfte für Russland
noch kommen denn auch auf der zivilen
Seite ist Putins aggressionspolitik
drauf und dran die russische Wirtschaft
zu ruinieren die internationalen
Sanktionen setzen wir inzwischen mächtig
zu dazu haben wir auf unserem
schwesterkanal visualökonomic unlängsten
eigenes Video gemacht den Link findet
ihr unten in der Beschreibung des
Weiteren russisches Öl in die EU und der
preisdecke 7 für einen Einbruch der
russischen Ölexperte um 11 % wobei der
Umsatzausfall aufgrund des Preisdrucks
nochmals höher sein dürfte einige
Lieferung nach China die im Januar auf
Tanker verladen werden sollen wurden
bereits um 5 bis 6 $ pro Barrel billiger
verkauft als üblich all das wird die
Staatseinnahmen des Gremmel empfindlich
schmälern und noch dazu sind viele junge
Russen im Krieg gefallen oder sie
fliehen aus Angst von der mobil machen
aus dem Land egal ob bei Immobilien
Autos oder alltagswahl von Lebensmitteln
die Bevölkerung ist hochgradig
verunsichert und die Konsum Laune ist
ihr mächtig vergangen Putins Reich
versinken wirtschaftlich und moralisch
langsam aber sicher in tiefer Depression
eine bei uns weniger bekannte
kriegsfolge ist dass viele Länder
bereits große dies mit Russland
storniert haben zum Beispiel haben
Indonesien und die Philippinen
Rüstungsgeschäfte mit der russischen
Industrie gekündigt im Falle Indonesien
es geht es um einen milliardenschweren
Vertrag über den Kauf von Soko 35
Kampfes sie werden nun durch
französische und US-Produkte ersetzt
Indonesiens 22 Milliarden Dollar Käufer
von US-amerikanischen und französischen
Kampfflugzeugen die Russland so 35 den
kürzeren Zug Indonesien kehrt Ende von
einem Deal mit Russland hin zu neuen
Kaufverträgen mit den USA und Frankreich
zeigt die wirksam die us-aktionen sind
und das ist noch nicht das Ende auch
politisch wird die internationale Lage
für den Kreml immer heikler
so hat eine Untersuchungskommission des
menschenrechtsrats der Vereinten
Nationen einen knallharten Bericht
veröffentlicht indem die Russische
Föderation beschuldigt wird bei ihrer
Invasion der Ukraine zahlreiche
Kriegsverbrechen begangen zu haben es
geht um Hinrichtungen Folter
Vergewaltigungen und natürlich um die
ständige Bombardierung von zivilen
Objekten und Infrastruktur und dabei
wird in diesem Report noch nicht einmal
richtig tief gegraben Russland ist also
in allen Ecken und Enden angeschlagen
die Reputation ruiniert der politische
Kontostand steckt so richtig tief in den
Miesen die Lage an der Front wird für
Putin mit dem einbrechenden Winter von
Tag zu Tag auch über warum Federchen
Frost für Russland drucken keine
Geschenke bringt sondern eher mächtig
Probleme auch darüber haben wir vor
kurzem hier offizielle Politik ein Video
gedreht mit dem Gefrieren der Böden
eröffnen sich den Ukraine wieder
Möglichkeiten ein schwach verteidigten
und Abschnitten durchzubrechen sollten
die Ukraine also ein weiteres Mal
vorstoßen können und hält die westliche
Hilfe für das Land an wie bisher ein
riskiert Russland eine katastrophale
Niederlage und die könnte auch das Ende
von Putin als macht aber selbst
angesichts dieser verzwickten bis
verzweifelten Lage des Kreises stellt
sich alle Welt eine bange Frage wäre
Russland bereit den bisherigen
konventionellen Konflikt zu eskalieren
und notfalls auch seine Atomwaffen
einzusetzen könnte dies das Blatt wenden
und könnte Putin wenn er mit der
atomaren Faust auf den Tisch legt
vielleicht wenigstens ein
Friedensabkommen erreichen mit dem der
Creme sein Gesicht waren kann oder gar
Kiel zur Kapitulation bewegen ja
ziemlich erschrecken diese Perspektive
wie realistisch sie ist das wollen wir
uns jetzt mal genauer ansehen und zwar
gleich nach einer kurzen werbeeinlage
für unseren tollen sponsorgeschlag also
auf geht's Sascha die Bienen ist ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keine verbindung Daten
mit lockt natürlich kann ein Wäsche
Private Networks VPN einen nicht vor
allem gefahren und muss nach wie vor
unsichtbar lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es steht hier für ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen darf zum einen
erschwert ist in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen letzten
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheit Features könnt
ihr eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen zum
Beispiel mit dem integrierten clean Web
das alle unerwünschten Cookies und
Popups blockt weiterer Vorteil eines
Vorbild ist dass ihr so tun könnt als
lehrt ihr in einem anderen Ort so könnt
ihr zum Beispiel auf Websites und
Internet
verfügbar werden ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sensur und
gioblocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes
anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internetfernsehen im Ausland
gucken willst du Aufschlag kein Problem
und das ist noch lange nicht alles mit
nur einem Server konnte wirklich alle
eure Endgeräte evt registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und zum Weihnachtsfest hatte eine
besonderes Angebot für euch auf Lager
wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt
85 % und oben deine ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu greift jetzt zu denn dies
Angebot ist zeitlich limitiert den Link
findet ihr wie immer in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video also nichts besorgt
euch und greift damit gleichzeitig auch
uns finanziell unter die Arme das könnte
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links den ich ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe mit dem Link
könnt ihr über Paypal aber auch mit
eurer Kreditkarte spenden wir sind euch
gerade jetzt in der Weihnachtszeit für
jede Unterstützung dank bei den damit
hätten wir uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr
und noch bessere Videos zu liefern und
nun lass uns schnell zur Beantwortung
unserer brennenden Fragen übergehen
könnte Russland in atomaren
befreiungsschlagwagen könnte es damit
das Blatt wenden aufgepasst
[Musik]
letzte Patrone
am 30 September 2022 unterzeichnete der
russische Präsident die Eingliederung
der ukrainischen oblastung und
jetztone in die Russische Föderation das
war eine Seite den Zweiten Weltkrieg in
Europa nicht mehr da gewesene gewaltsame
Gebiet Aneignung deren Ausmaß selbst die
Annexion der grins 2014 weit in den
Schatten stellte es sieht so aus als
wollte Putin mit dieser Annexion dem
russischen Volk zeigen dass dieser Krieg
einen Sinn hat das Russland weit davon
entfernt ist zu verlieren sondern dass
man nennenswerte Territorium gewonnen
und die dortigen Bewohner befreit habe
das Problem ist dass die Realität
ziemlich anders aussieht zwar der Kreml
seine annektiertes Neuland wohl weiß ich
nicht klar abgegrenzt was die Sachen von
vornherein ziemlich absolut verliebt
doch die ukrainische Person und die
Vertreibung der russischen Truppen über
den Japan danach doppelt gemütigen denn
kaum hatte die russische Propaganda im
ganzen Land lauthals kundgetan das Herz
und Notfall immer eine russische Stadt
sei wahr ist das schon nicht mehr doch
darin liegt jetzt die Crocs nach der
exaktion gelten die ukrainischen
offensiv der Person oder im Gebiet
johannskraus russischer Sicht nun
eigenen russischen Territorium und was
bedeutet das nun nach der Definition des
gremmels wird Russland jetzt also auf
eigenem Boden angegriffen und ist auch
noch drauf und dran eigene Gebiete bzw
das was es da verhält zu verlieren
eigentlich wäre es spätestens jetzt
nicht mehr möglich offiziell von einer
militärischen spezialoperation zu
sprechen also einem begrenzteneinsatz im
Ausland wenn Russland hier selbst
angegriffen wird müsste das doch
eigentlich ein neuer vaterländischer
Krieg sein es wäre der dritte nach
Napoleons Invasion 1814 und Hitlers
Russlandfeldzug 1941 tatsächlich so ist
Putin in seiner neuesten redet diesen
Vergleich um die Russen auf einen langen
und entbehrungsreichen Konflikt
vorzubereiten
und hier liegt das Problem liebe
visualpolitik Zuschauer Vladimir Putin
agiert wie ein Spielsüchtiger
Pokerspieler der seine Einsatz immer
weiter erhöht das ist zumindest die
Erfahrung die wir bisher gemacht haben
das hat viele Alarmglocken schrillen
lassen denn Putin verliert momentan
jedes Blatt 2 November 2022 Kiew
bereitet 435 Schutzräume für den Fall
eines russischen Atom Angriffs vor in
die Engel getrieben geht demütigt
besiegt den Verlauf des Krieges zu
ändern scheint den Kremmen praktisch
unmöglich aber könnte Putins Regime
nicht einen Atomschlag versuchen der den
besten und die Ukraine zwingen würde
einen Waffenstillstand auszuhandeln
ließe sich mit der nuklearen Option
erreichen dass der kriegt jetzt endet
und Putin sich vor den Russen mit den
erzielten Gewinnen brüsten kann leider
leider sprechen wir nicht von einer
irrationalen Hypothese
fakt ist Russland hat seine Armee in der
Ukraine bereits Kapital aufgerieben aber
es hat eben immer noch einen Trumpf sein
Atomwaffenarsenal es geht hier gar nicht
so sehr um die massiven Atombomben auf
Interkontinentalraketen die ganz Städte
und Region austauschen können sondern um
ein Arsenal von etwa 2000 taktischen
Atombomben mit einer springkraft
zwischen einer und 10 Kilo Tonnen es
handelt sich also um viele kleinere
Waffen die aber noch nirgendwo auf der
Welt im Kampf zu Einsatz gekommen sind
sie sind nicht dazu gedacht eine Stadt
im Erdboden gleich zu machen sondern um
eine konventionelle Armee auf dem
Schlachtfeld zu bekämpfen diese Waffen
könnte die kleine Spitze in einem Moment
der Verzweiflung einsetzen um im
Handstreich die Kriegslage drehen zu
wollen wir haben unser eigenes
militärisches Potential wenn jemand
denkt dass wir es bei einer ernsthaften
Bedrohung nicht einsetzen werden dann
wird er sich mit Kopf stellvertreten
sondern dass du mal Ausschusses für
Außenbeziehungen stellen wir uns vor das
Russland gezwungen ist seine stärksten
Waffen gegen das ukrainische Regime
einzusetzen das eine große angelegte
Aggression begangen hat die die Existenz
unseres Staates gefährdet ich glaube
dass die nat wenn eine solchen Szenario
selbst nicht direkt in den Konflikt
eingreifen wird mit WDF Putins
politische Adjutanten sagen das ja auch
offen heraus Putin selbst drohte schon
leicht zu Beginn der Invasion damit
Atomwaffen einzusetzen seht selbst
Russland ist nach wie vor eine der
mächtigsten Atomstaaten außerdem hat es
einen gewissen Vorsprung bei einer Reihe
von hochmodernen Waffen in diesem
Zusammenhang sollte es keinen Zweifel
geben dass jeder potenzielle Angreifer
mit einer Niederlage und unheilvollen
Konsequenzen rechnen muss wenn er unser
Land direkt angreift Wladimir Putin und
als im Herbst die großen Rückschläge auf
dem Schlachtfeld kamen wollten sich auch
die nuklear angereicherten Drohungen aus
dem Grillen das hilft Nachrichten wie
diese zu erklären 10 November 2022
oberste US-General drängt auf Diplomatie
in der Ukraine deren beiden Berater
Abwinken der Vorsitzende der
generalstoffchef dafür die Ukraine
sollten versuchen ihre Gewinne einfach
Verhandlungstisch zu festigen
23 November 2022 Krieg in der Ukraine
emmanuell macron kündigt an dass er in
den nächsten Tagen einen direkten
Kontakt mit Wladimir Putin haben wird
die bedeutenden ukrainischen Vorstöße
die Ausland an der Front in die
Defensive getrieben haben Stärken nun
also in gewisser Weise dennoch das
Bestreben mit Russland einen
Waffenstillstand auszuhandeln denn es
gilt eine weitere Eskalation des
Konflikts zu verhindern dabei steht
immer die Frage im Raum wenn Russland
drauf und dran ist im Krieg zu verlieren
warum greift es dann nicht auf sein
Atomwaffenarsenal zurück schließlich
hätte die Ukraine den nichts
Gleichwertiges entgegenzusetzen nun es
gibt sechs gute Gründe warum ist
unwahrscheinlich ist das Russland sein
Atomwaffen auseinander diese Lage
einsetzt oder besser gesagt sechs gute
Gründe warum der Einsatz von Atomwaffen
ein kapitaler Fehler für Russland wäre
wollt ihr wissen welche genau die sind
dann passt jetzt gut auf
[Musik]
der Einsatz von Atomwaffen um eine
Niederlage in der Ukraine zu verhindern
erscheint für Russland durchaus sinnvoll
zu sein so lange man diese Variante
nicht in aller Ruhe analysiert hat in
Wahrheit gibt es gute Gründe zur Annahme
des Moskau in der Ukraine keine
Atomwaffen einsetzen wird wir können
dafür sechs wichtige Gründe hervorheben
erstens es gibt bessere militärische
Alternativen wie bitte etwas besseres
als Atomwaffen ja genau ihr habt euch
nicht verhört lass mich das erklären die
logische Option beim Einsatz von
Atomwaffen als macht Demonstration in
diesem Krieg wäre damit die ukrainische
Armee anzugreifen doch anders als
vielleicht angenommen wird ein solcher
atomeinsatz den Konflikten extrem
eskalieren aber gleichzeitig wohl keinen
militärischen Vorteil bringen
[Musik]
taktische Atomwaffen sind in der Regel
mit kleinen Sprengköpfen ausgestattet
die für den Angriff auf große und
konzentrierte Kampftruppen ausgelegt
sind aber die ukrainische Armee operiert
eben nicht mit großen
gruppenansammlungen sondern ist ständig
in Bewegung so dass der Schaden begrenzt
wäre die Wirkung von Atombomben unter 10
Kilo Tonnen ist sogar geringer als die
von hochpräzisen Artillerie und
Vakuumpumpen wie sie bereits anders und
eingesetzt wurden
um die militärischen Fähigkeiten der
Ukraine zu zerschmettern müssten also
dutzende taktische Atomwaffen eingesetzt
werden us-militärpläne aus der Zeit des
Kalten Krieges dann beispielsweise vor
136 taktische Atombomben um eine 100 km
lange Front zu räumen die derzeitige
Frontlinie zwischen der Ukraine und
Russland erstreckt sich aber über mehr
als 600 Kilometer
atomwaffen sind am nützlichsten wenn man
sie nicht einsetzt es bringt einfach
keinen Vorteil auf dem Schlachtfeld eine
Atomwaffen
in Europa natürlich könnten diese Waffen
für Angriffe auf Kraftwerke oder
Infrastruktur Objekte von Nutzen sein
aber ihre Anwendung würde eine größere
Anzahl von Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
ohne nennenswerte Vorteile zu schaffen
das bringt uns direkt zum zweiten Grund
[Musik]
der Einsatz von Atomwaffen würde für
Russland nicht das Ende des Problems
bedeuten sondern eher das Gegenteil es
wäre das Ende der Lösung ein Atomschlag
egal welchen Kalibers würde eine
schallende internationale Verurteilung
Russlands nach sich ziehen eine Schmacht
die weitaus größer wäre als die vom
Krieg selbst verursachte der Druck auf
Russland wäre enorm dadurch Sanktion
weltweit ausgeweitet wurden
anschließlich der sekundären Sanktion
die auch noch relativ Russland
freundlich gestimmte Länder wie Indien
oder die vereinigten arabischen emiratet
ziemlich unfreundlich werden müssen der
Druck des Westens oder ein
unvorstellbares Ausmaß erreichen und
Russland wurde sozusagen zu einer
moralisch verstrahlten Zone werden
Putins reich wäre dann so etwas wie ein
riesiges Nordkorea oder gar noch
schlimmer das würde natürlich den
Todesstoß für die Reste einer modernen
russischen Gesellschaft aber auch für
die Business Elite des Landes bedeuten
ihnen Zuflucht bieten nein jede Form der
Zusammenarbeit wäre Tabu Putins Russland
wäre auf lange Zeit absolut toxisch
selbst den Kreml wohlgesonnene Länder
wie China haben bereits deutlich gemacht
dass dies für sie eine rote Linie
darstellt angesichts der schweren
Rückschläge Russlands auf dem
Schlachtfeld haben sowohl nur Deli als
auch Peking ihrer Warnungen verstärkt
das Putin unter keinen Umständen auf die
nukleare Option zurückgreifen dürfen die
Regierung Modi hat den russischen
Verteidigungsminister klar gemacht dass
ein Einsatz von Atomwaffen absolut tabu
sein muss dies war nur ein Teil der
offenbar konzentrierten Bemühungen der
indischen Regierung Russland davon
abzuhalten auch in Bewegung zu ziehen im
November sprach der chinesische
Präsident mit dem deutschen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz über das Thema
Ski und schoss sparen sich dabei nicht
nur gegen den Einsatz von Atomwaffen aus
sie gingen sogar noch weiter und
verurteilten sogar die Anhörung des
Einsatzes solche Waffen sie nannten
keine Namen aber nur eine einzige Macht
in der Welt rote zu diesen Zeitpunkt mit
dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen Ski und Mode
haben verstanden dass der Einsatz von
Atomwaffen durch Putin eine strategische
Katastrophe Russland sondern auch für
sie und die ganze Welt darstellen wird
denn sollte Putin auch nur einen
einzigen atomspringen Kopf in der
Ukraine zu finden würde er die gesamte
geostrategische Ordnung wann und wie
Atomwaffen überhaupt eingesetzt werden
sprengen selbst China käme dann aus
purem Eigeninteresse nicht umher
Russland hart und demonstrativ zu
bestrafen und zu isolieren denn wenn es
zu einem neuen Standard in der
Weltpolitik würde dass ein nuklear
bewaffnet der Stadt Atomwaffen einsetzen
kann um seine territoriale Ausdehnung
und Eroberung zu sichern dann bricht das
gesamte Gebäude der globalen nicht
verbreitungsabkommen für Atomwaffen
zusammen der Drang kleinere Länder sich
Atomwaffen zu beschaffen könnte die
internationalen Beziehungen zum Nachteil
der derzeitigen Atommächte
einschließlich China verändert vor allem
viele südostasiatische Länder würden
sich kopfüber in den Aufbau eigener
Atomwaffenarsenal stürzen und sich
abzusichern und all das würde passieren
ohne das Russland dadurch einen
militärische Vorteil erlangt fakt ist
die unverblümmt vorgetragene Botschaft
aus Peking scheint in Moskau verstanden
worden zu sein am 7 dezember 2022
bekräftigte Putin daher folgendes
um ehrlich zu sein die Gefahr eines
Atomkriegs wächst aber Russland wird
nicht der Erste sein der Atomwaffen
einsetzt wir wissen was atomwaffen sind
aber wir werden nicht durch die Welt
laufen nur diese Waffen wie Rasiermesser
schwingen aber wir reden nicht nur über
politische und wirtschaftliche
Reaktionen vielleicht gibt es auch eine
militärische Reaktion Washington sagte
es klipp und klar der Einsatz von
Atomwaffen würde eine heftige Reaktion
des Westens nach sich ziehen das haben
sowohl Verteidigungsministerin als auch
der Vorsitzende der generalstoffchef und
der nationale Sicherheitsberater Jax
Halle gegen russischen Beamten deutlich
gemacht wir haben den gremme direkt
unter vier Augen und auf höchster Ebene
mitgeteilt dass jeder Einsatz von
Atomwaffen katastrophale Folgen für
Russland hätte und dass die Vereinigten
Staaten und unsere Verbündeten
entschlossen reagieren werden und wir
haben klar und deutlich gesagt was das
bedeuten würde
Nationaler Sicherheitsberater des Weißen
Hauses wir wissen nicht genau welche Art
von reaktionszahlen meinte aber sie
hatte durch das die NATO im Falle eines
Atom Angriffs mit einem großen
angelegten konventionellenschlag
reagieren würde um die russische
Streitkräfte in der Ukraine zu
vernichten und die Souveränität der
Ukraine zu garantieren
eine andere Option wäre die Ukraine mit
weitaus moderneren und tödlicheren
Waffen zu versorgen als bisher zum
Beispiel militärisches Gerät für
Angriffe über große Entfernung oder
Kampfflugzeuge in Flottenstärke es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich dass das
Ergebnis einer solchen Reaktion die
Vernichtung der ohnehin schon
geschwächten russischen Streit macht in
der Ukraine wäre soweit wir sind mit den
Einsatz taktischer Atomwaffen auf
ukrainischen Boden und nicht mit einem
Angriff auf die NATO was bedeutet dass
die NATO auf konventionelle Weise
reagieren sollte aber die Antwort wäre
verheerend und ich denke das ist die
klare Botschaft die das nato-bündnis im
Moment an Russland sendet wenn ihr Frau
polnischer Außenminister wir haben alle
gesehen was mit Russland konventionelle
Armee passiert ist auf den ersten Blick
schien es Russland könnte die Ukraine
schnell überrennen aber Korruption
fehlte Ausrüstung ausbildungsinfizite
und schlechte Wartung haben den
Kriegsverlauf zu einem Albtraum werden
lassen deshalb ist davon auszugeben
Russland atomwaffen sind nicht unbedingt
in einem besseren Zustand als eine
konventionellen Streitkräfte laute
russischen insider berichten ist nur ein
Bruchteil der teils Jahrzehnte alten
atommunition wirklich einsatzbereit und
ihr könnt euch ausmalen was eine
Fehlzündung oder ein Versagen dieser
Waffen im Einsatz bedeuten würde sie
könnten sogar der eigenen Seite mehr
Schaden zufügen als den Feind ein
derartiges versagen könnte dann der
Todesstoß für die herrschende
Krämerbrücke sein und ehrlich gesagt so
unwahrscheinlich sind Pleiten Pech und
Pannen selbst bei den vermeintlichen
prioritären atomstreitkräften nicht
schließlich ist Russland ein Land aus
den Nachrichten wie diese kommen 8
dezember 2020 Diebe stehen Funkgeräte
eines russischen
weltuntergangsflugzeugs Diebe haben
elektronische Geräte aus einem
russischen Militärflugzeug gestohlen
deswegen seiner Funktion im
Atomwaffenarsenal des Landes als
weltuntergangsflugzeug bekannt ist und
natürlich bestätige Gefahr das ist zu
einer exponentiellen Eskalation kommt
das ist Grund Nummer 5
seit dem Kalten Krieg ist klar dass
Atomwaffen ein Mittel der Abschreckung
und nicht der Aggression sind der
Einsatz von Atomwaffen könnte am Ende
unvorstellbaren Schaden für alle
bedeuten auf diese Art wirkte das
Gleichgewicht der gegenseitigen
gesicherten Vernichtung ein
Sicherheitsmechanismus den auch
Russlands Führungsebene verinnerlicht
hat alle dort sind sich der Konsequenzen
bewusst und sie alle haben auch Familien
und Freunde schließlich ist auch Putin
kein Selbstmörder sondern im Gegenteil
ein selbstverliebter Narzisst der sich
an sein Leben klammert wie kaum ein
zweiter wer aus Angst vor kovic ein
sechs Meter langen Tisch zwischen sich
und seine Gäste klemmt hat sicher nicht
die Eier sich und die Menschheit nuklear
auszulöschen diese apokalyptische Vision
macht den Einsatz von Atomwaffen auch im
eigenen Land extrem unpopulär auch wenn
ein paar Schreihälse in russischen
Propaganda Fernsehen am liebsten mit der
atomkeule auf den ganzen kollektiven
Westen einreichen würden doch es bleibt
bei verbal Attacken nehmen wir zum
Beispiel all jene nüchtern
kalkulierenden Extremisten die etwa
igelkiste als paramilitärischer
in Don Bass 2014 von zaunbrach und
unlängst wegen des Abschlusses von Flug
mh17 in den Haar in Abwesenheit und
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt wurde
selbst diese üble Kriegstreiber sagt
deutlich dass der Einsatz von Atomwaffen
ein Fehler und sogar ein Verbrechen wäre
denn so die umwerfende Logik dieses
ultra-nationalisten da die Ukraine ja
eigentlich ein Teil Russland seien
würden sich dadurch ja selbst atomar
bombardieren all diese Gründe helfen uns
zu verstehen warum Atomwaffen nach 1945
nie wieder eingesetzt wurden wieder im
Koreakrieg noch im Vietnamkrieg noch in
Afghanistan noch bisher im Ukraine Krieg
obwohl russlandsverluste bereits
gigantisch sind selbst wenn Putin den
Verstand verlieren und auf den
sprichwörtlichen roten Knopf drücken
würde die Folgen während so schwer wegen
dass die Motivation in seinem Umfeld
doch sehr groß sein dürfte ihn im
letzten Moment zu verstoßen denn wenn
uns die Geschichte die wir am Anfang
dieses Videos ausführlich bemüht haben
etwas leer dann dass die nackte Realität
am Ende doch jedes Zick mal
durchgespieltes Szenario aushebeln kann
und deshalb liebe visualpolitik
Zuschauer ist es zumindest aller Welt
die nicht völlig verrückt geworden ist
doch mehr als unwahrscheinlich das
Russland diesen Konflikt seine
Atomwaffen auspackt und zündet Russland
wollte mit seinen Atom Drohungen den
Westen einschüchtern damit er die
Unterstützung der Ukraine aufgibt oder
zumindest einschränkt fatalerweise sind
einige einflussreiche Stimmen im Westen
auf diesen blöd hereingefallen und waren
bereits nuklearen Drohungen nachzugehen
sie nennen sich selbst Realisten so wie
zum Beispiel der amerikanische
Politikwissenschaftler doch wie wir
bereits in einem früheren Video über die
großen Ukraine Mythen aufgedeckt haben
diese selbst ernannten Realisten haben
nicht nur die Stärke der russischen
Streitkräfte drastisch überschätzt oder
die Bereitschaft Putins ein Angriff
loszuschlagen und unterschätzt nein sie
haben eine lange Historie darin die
globale Macht Dynamik immer wieder
falsch einzuschätzen echt der Realismus
wurde anerkennen dass eine Vielzahl von
Akteuren in der internationalen Ordnung
hat daran gearbeitet hat und weiterhin
hart daran arbeiten wird Russland vom
Einsatz von Atomwaffen abzuhalten und
die wahre realistische Position besteht
können sich auf die großen Hindernisse
zu konzentrieren die Russland davon
abhalten in der Ukraine Atomwaffen
einzusetzen hierzu gehört auch dass sich
die Ukraine keinen strategischen Fehler
leisten kann ein Friedensabkommen ohne
große Zugeständnisse sagt ins Russland
würde das Land dauerhaft ins Verderben
stürzen würde es nur ausnutzen um wieder
seine Kräfte zu sammeln und zu einem
besseren Zeitpunkt sein Ziel weiter zu
verfolgen die Ukraine die so viel
erlitten und schon erkämpft haben würden
das nur schwer akzeptieren können und
auch für uns im Westen wäre es eine
kardinale pleite aber die Frage von
Friedensverhandlungen und wie ein Ende
des Krieges aussehen könnte ist schon
wieder ein Thema für ein weiteres Video
vergessen bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt
mit Glöckchen und ist auf gar keinen
Fall zu verpassen und wenn das Abo
gebongt ist seit ihr mit eurer Meinung
im Kommentarbereich an der Reihe denkt
ihr nach allem was er gesehen habt das
Buch jetzt Russland ist wirklich wagen
wird Atomwaffen einzusetzen glaubt ihr
dass das Ende des Krieges nahe ist oder
er sich noch lange hinziehen oder so wie
Putin ist unlängst andeutet hinterlasst
eure Meinung in den Kommentaren und wenn
wenn wir dieses Video interessant
konntet vergessen bitte nicht es zu
liken und mit euren Freunden zu teilen
gerade jetzt zu Weihnachtszeit freuen
wir uns natürlich auch über eine Spende
von euch den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]